khloe kardashian has the ultimate clap
back amid criticism over expecting baby
number two with ex tristan thompson i
just want to live my life and be happy
chloe posted a bikini pic showing off
her ripped abs while enjoying the good
life on a private yacht
but it's coco's reminder to the haters
in her caption that has us over here
clapping quote don't forget the crown
may tilt at times but it never falls
exactly spoken like a true queen chloe
is keeping her head held high despite
the chatter over the addition of her and
tristan's second child a baby boy via
surrogate the baby number two news comes
just months after the nba star's
paternity scandal where he cheated on
coco and fathered a son with fitness
model marylee nichols i wanted to
believe that tristan could change i
wanted to trust him a source recently
told e.t chloe's moved on from the
athlete and from what we can see coco's
unbothered and focused on the positive
we're told chloe's not even worried
about tristan being spotted out with
other women as he lives it up and enjoys
the single life
chloe's main focus spending quality time
with their four-year-old daughter true
i'm focused on work and like taking care
of me my body and soul and true and i
just i'm having so much fun with her and
over on tick-tock the mother-daughter
duo is doing exactly that check out this
vid of true living her best life during
their tropical getaway using a throwback
sound of chloe and scott disick
i have a busy
week
do you
thursday
novo
vegas friday then i have a spray tan at
8 45. oh my god we're told chloe is
true's primary caretaker but both
parents main priority keeping their girl
happy our source says they want to make
sure that true has the best life
possible while keeping her happy and
away from any tension
he's a really hands-on dad and so it's
just easy to co-parent with him as for
coco and tristan's dynamic well we're
told they only speak when they're
co-parenting their relationship is
strained but tolerable but ultimately as
long as tristan continues to be a good
father to her children that's all that
matters i think everyone has to handle
their co-parenting situation in their
own style
[Music]